ist Cremissimo wirklich so bellissimo
Sebastian reißt nach Italien und
vergleicht das Industrie als von
Langnese mit traditioneller
italienischer Eiscreme da sieht man doch
schon blind dass hier Welten
Aufeinandertreffen Sebastian deckt auf
mit welcher Zutat krimissimo mehr
Volumen ins Eis trickst die haben es
drauf die haben Sie richtig drauf
[Musik]
ich hasse süß aber ich liebe Eis
auf seit 1998 hat Langnese Cremissimo im
Sortiment die vorratspotion für die
heimische Gefriertruhe mit ganz
besonderer Cremigkeit
klassische Eiscreme
bohrt man und bohrt man man muss warten
bis ein bisschen angetaut ist und dann
kann man es essen remissimo verspricht
dagegen Eisvergnügen ohne jede Mühe
[Musik]
ich habe das gerade aus dem Gefrierfach
geholt man kann auch die Eiskristalle
drauf erkennen und schauen sie her das
ist so cremig wie muss so Schokolade
genialer Trick oder
der krimissimo Trick
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Produktentwickler Sebastian lege will
dem Rezept auf die Spur kommen dazu
schaut er sich die Zutatenliste an
eins muss man den ja lassen den Freunden
von Langnese es geht mit entrahmter
Milch los
das ist komplett entfettete Milch
dann wasserzucker Glukosesirup Kokosfett
Fructose Glukose Fructose Sirup ein
Molken Erzeugnis vermahlene
Vanilleschoten Stabilisatoren
Johannesburg
natürlich ist Vanillearoma Farbstoff
Karotin die Romantik ist jetzt schon
flöten gegangen bei mir
der wahre Trick steckt gar nicht in den
Zutaten
Sebastian liege staunt wie wenig Inhalt
in einer Packung steckt
das ist echt der Knaller die können
zaubern
wirklich jeder weiß ein halber Liter
sind 500 Gramm
hier sind 650 Gramm
1300 ml
die haben es drauf die haben es richtig
drauf aus 650 Gramm Eismasse werden 1,3
Liter Cremissimo Langnese gelingt es das
Volumen zu verdoppeln wie geht das
[Musik]
damit das Volumen im Eis auch erhalten
bleibt brauchen wir einiges an
bindemittelnmehl dann kommt noch
Johannisbrotkernmehl wenn Sie schon mal
im Süden im Urlaub waren und haben die
Bäume gesehen die so bananenartige
Früchte hatten ne so bananenartige
Früchte mit zu dicken Kern drinne das
ist der Johannisbrotbaum und daraus wird
das Bindemittel geworden
Bindemittel Pflanzenfett und weitere
industriezutaten daraus besteht
Cremissimo einfach bei Zimmertemperatur
zusammenrühren fertig ist die Eismasse
das Einfrieren will Sebastian lege
direkt beim Abfüllen mit erledigen
wie die Industrie nur selbst gebaut
herzlich willkommen in leges Eisfabrik
nicht ganz so professionell wie bei
Langnese aber das Prinzip fast genauso
das ist ein
vollautomatischer fließender Prozess
Zutaten konditioniert verrührt verpumpt
gefrostet gefüllt fertig und schon bei
Ihrem Supermarkt um die Ecke eine
Bohrmaschine ist der Antrieb für die
Pumpe so gelangt die flüssige Eismasse
in die selbst gebaute gefrieranlage
[Musik]
perfekt reicht so ein bisschen Luft rein
der rote Hahn öffnet die Druckluft die
strömt in das Rührwerk durch die Luft
wird die Eismasse langsam immer
schaumiger
[Musik]
Vanillesoße und genau jetzt wird zu Eis
mit einem co2-feuerlöscher sorgt
Sebastian lege für die nötigen
Minustemperaturen die schaumige Eismasse
wird so luftig
richtig schön schaumig doppeltes Volumen
so trägt man bei Eiscreme
Standard Speiseeis enthält etwa 30
Prozent Luft erst krimissimo gelingt es
mehr als die Hälfte Luft einzufrieren
gut für die Cremigkeit und für das
Geschäft
Cremissimo enthält 50% Luft und hat
damit einen Trend gesetzt auch das Eis
von Mövenpick setzt auf den krimissimo
Trick
tragen das enthält kaum Luft und ist
hart die Discounter Folgen exakt dem
Erfolgsrezept von Langnese
Langnese vermarktet die viele Luft
geschickt mit dem Eis wird ein ganz
bestimmtes Lebensgefühl verkauft
für die deutschen ist Italien und Eis
quasi identisch
und sie
Essen mit dem Eis essen Sie Urlaub und
Essen sich dran und essen Sie baden
gehen in mir
wie viel Italien steckt wirklich in
Cremissimo das will Sebastian lege auf
der anderen Seite der Alpen selbst
herausfinden
[Musik]
Bongiorno Italia ich bin gerade im
Verona und treffe die beste eismacherin
der Welt ich bin wirklich gespannt ob
sie zu Langnese krimissimo Belissimo
sagt
Giovanna bonat sie belegte bei den
renommierten Gelato World Masters als
beste Frau Rang 3
sie weiß wie gutes Eis im Mutterland der
eiskultur hergestellt wird
köstlich aus mmh bitte oh danke
[Musik]
Weltmeister ist
Giovanna verspricht Eis aus besten
Zutaten
[Musik]
ich weiß sie denken jetzt
ist er mir hier ein Vorsicht
bitte danke schön das ist Sorte Nummer 4
und guck doch mal die Farbe der Tanzi
Vanille auf der Oberfläche
kannst du mir zeigen wie du das machst
natürlich auf geht's
die eiswerkstatt willkommen
Zucker Johannisbrotkernmehl als
Bindemittel Eigelb Sahne und Milch
bilden bei Giovanna die Basis für
Vanilleeis alles Bio alles regional und
traditionell hergestellt
auch die ist extra Klasse kommt aus
Madagaskar solche Vanille kostet 600 €
pro Kilo Giovanna
Zutaten dazu
[Musik]
schön Zitrone und Orangenschale rein
das Sieb setzt sie in die Eismaschine
dann füllt sie die sahnige Eismasse ein
die Maschine arbeitet ganz ohne
Druckluft cremig ist das Eis trotzdem
ist das schön ich bin schwer verliebt
gerade
Sebastian lege hat Deutschlands
beliebtestes Vanilleeis mitgebracht
Cremissimo
und hier die beliebteste Eiscreme
Deutschlands
[Musik]
sofort das Eis ist zu leicht Sebastian
ich möchte dir etwas zeigen
44 Gramm also 44 Gramm ein Becher
Langnese cremiss
78 Gramm gleiche Füllmenge doch viel
viel mehr Produkte
enthaltene vanillemus
gegen ihr Weltmeister ist da sieht man
doch schon blind dass hier Welten
aufeinandertreffen
vor der Arena in Verona macht Sebastian
lege das Experiment kann Cremissimo
gegen Hand gemacht des Eisen bestehen
lieben auch Italiener industrielles
luft-
Handwerk oder Industrie wer trifft den
Geschmack der Italiener besser ich
bevorzuge das hier oh okay das ist
besser das ist sehr gut das ist das
beliebteste Eis Deutschlands ja das habt
Ihr uns gut nachgemacht
[Gelächter]
in Verona zunächst die Stichprobe zu
gewinnen
das gelbe Eis ich nehme das hier
doch dann holt giovannas Eis Punkt um
Punkt auf und schlägt das
Industrieprodukt am Ende deutlich
[Musik]
Cremissimo kann in Verona einige
Italiener überzeugen
Giovanna hat gewonnen aber auch ganz
schön vielen hat das Langnese Cremissimo
hier in Italien geschmeckt das hätte ich
nie gedacht auf gar keinen Fall
den Namen Langnese haben die meisten
Italiener übrigens noch nie gehört die
Firma ist zwar fast auf der ganzen Welt
vertreten allerdings überall unter
verschiedenen Namen in der Türkei heißt
die Cremissimo Variante frigola und
enthält 45% Luft in Frankreich und
Italien heißt krimissimo Karte doch mit
48% Luft und in das finnische Krimi hat
Langnese sogar 58% Luft gemischt und ich
glaube die Produktentwickler die lachen
sich schlapp wenn die wissen dass wir
das so gerne kaufen aus ganz wenig ganz
viel gemacht und ein luftig cremiger
Genuss guten Appetit